alright everybody was going on welcome
to another robotics with the Raspberry
Pi tutorial video it is now time to test
our autonomous Raspberry Pi robot so we
just have this front sensor so that's
the only sensor that we have for
distance so hopefully we're going to
avoid objects in front of us but we're
probably going to run into objects
behind us
also we're a little uncertain how it's
going to handle any sort of angles on
the wall but here we are to live test it
to find out so I've logged into my PI
I'm going to go ahead and change
directory into robotics and we're going
to go ahead and run sudo python robot 6
dot hi let's go ahead and run it see how
we do so far so good I don't think we've
run into anything we did have at least
one to close that happened almost ran
into the fridge there and then I might
have actually run in so far so good this
might prove problematic nope hmm so
actually not too bad it's getting a
little closer than I'd like as far as
getting on the front end there but
actually not not too bad I'm pretty
happy with that let's go ahead and run
that again see how we do again
I'm surprised we haven't crashed
anything on the back end
there's no sensor there so we're just
getting lucky I suppose picked a good
good time lengths to move forward or
something a reverse rather so anyways
with these random movements
so far we've avoided any major collision
I'm pretty impressed we've seen some
pretty extreme angles even here and
haven't had too much issue even that one
that's pretty tight angle - or large
angle rather okay so looks like we're
good the only thing you might want to
tweak is how close the distance so
anything under 15 that's when we chose
to panic here but you might prefer 25 or
something like that so you have to
account for a reaction time it also
depends what you're doing you know if
you've got something like a Roomba or
something that's gonna go around and
clean your floor you want it to kind of
get close to the edges so you might want
something like fifteen severly garage to
the fridge there so that might be
something you're going for but if that's
not your goal then why not err on the
side of caution
and not get too close but it looks like
it's actually doing pretty good not
running into anything on the front side
anyways so many ways that's going to
conclude this video and our first level
of autonomy with this robot hopefully
you guys enjoyed if you have any
questions or comments feel free to leave
them below as always thanks for watching
thanks for all the support and
subscriptions and it's all next time